Hey everyone, welcome back to another episode of the Grand Prixquel Podcast where we discuss all things feeder series.
On this episode, we're going to be doing a recap of the F2 and F3 rounds at the Hungaroring, as well as Italian F4 at Mugello.
Your hosts today are myself Evan, Alex and Nova.
So I guess we can get straight into F2 then, and straight into qualifying.
We had a top 10 of Maini, Camara, Leon, Durksen, Inthraphuvasak, Van Hoepen, Tsolov, Beganovic, Mini, Montoya.
Top 10 of all time I think.
Agreed. It's really unfortunate we didn't get to see Dunne in the top 10.
He ended up P17, he had a suspension failure, as he said on his Instagram after the session.
But I think just the top 3 alone, Maini, Camara, Leon, it's the concept to say the least.
It's the concept. We know that the Invicta is capable of that, and we've seen Leon set a pole before.
The Maini thing definitely took me off guard.
We're at the same thing that I said yesterday with Inthraphuvasak also being P5.
How's the ART just really going off this year?
And it's obviously the year where there's like drivers you wouldn't really expect.
I'm sorry, but you didn't really care for it.
Last year we had drivers and the years before we had drivers that were relevant and had shots at F1,
but now we're stuck in Maini and Inthraphuvasak. Come on.
And it's also really interesting to see people like Tsolov and Mini lower down the order.
I mean, Campos had a weird strategy.
I've seen some people on Twitter discuss it, that they thought that if Tsolov was on the strategy they put Leon on,
he would probably be P3, but we never know.
I think he could have done more probably, but also Hungary is a track that just leads to a bit of chaos every time.
And we managed to get Montoya on sprint pole again. Oh god.
Montoya, Montoya. I guess, you know, perfect segue over to the sprint race then where we've got a bit more things.
Montoya initially, I say initially, Montoya initially actually did listen to our advice,
which means he actually listens to the podcast then, allegedly.
He pressed the throttle and he actually got away pretty well over Mini.
I think in the first couple of laps, he already opened up at least an over one second gap.
It was like a one point something second gap.
So it's lovely, great to see from him, obviously.
But then when we had DRS and then the gap closed a bit, but I think he pressed the throttle.
So our episode title came true.
He actually did learn and he learned to press the throttle.
JPM probably very happy that he probably did that for once.
Dunne as well. Dunne's entire race was just, I think his suspension was still pretty messed up.
And I think Rodin just didn't, I guess, didn't fix it properly.
Maybe they couldn't, something along those lines, but he had a bad race.
Clearly did not finish in the top eight because I don't have the results here of where he finished.
But yeah, bad time for him still after everything happened qualifying for him.
If Montoya listened to us and we got him to press the throttle, maybe it's time we start giving more advice.
My next advice would be stop crashing.
We all just got to be a bit more down to earth and more safe.
Don't try any huge moves.
The way Tsolov did on Montoya, like, you know, it was surely moved down the inside where it's like, yeah, that's a Red Bull move.
But it was a move that was not necessarily needed for the championship.
Let's just say that because–did we go through the finished…did we go through the final race results?
Well, yeah, let's go through the top eight then.
So we had Mini winning the race.
Beganovic, Van Hoepen on the podium.
Camara, Maini, Inthraphuvasak, Durksen and Stenshorne to round off the top eight.
Because Tsolov just pretty much absolutely threw away a podium there.
Due to that, obviously Camara also gained positions for free.
Mini had more points for free that, you know, if he would have been on a podium, like Mini would have gained like two or three points in him or something like that.
But now that he's off the podium, it was like 10 points gained.
You know, it's always go for the gap, go for the win, you know, I get it.
But simultaneously, I think in this case, going for this gap.
And if you know it's Montoya and you know Montoya is maybe not the one driver that always is the best at also, you know, reacting to what you're going to put on the track.
Maybe it's time to be a bit more safe, be a bit more in touch with your safety side.
Look, safety is great and all, but it also doesn't give us absolutely interesting moves that we see.
Like again, like we mentioned with the Montoya-Tsolov incident, which he did actually, once we got into the feature race, what I recall, he actually did get that move done, and he got it done properly and safely this time.
But, you know, if we were all that safe, then we wouldn't have even gotten that move at all this entire weekend.
The thing is just, I actually pretty much, I think Tsolov is a good driver and I think, interesting because like, you know, he's in conversation to be potentially up for an F1 seat.
But this kind of thing just ruins your race and it's the kind of thing that can also, in long term, not just cost you the championship, but also cost you the whole ass F1 seat.
And I'm just saying it would be pretty sh*t if that happens for him and I'd be really disappointed.
Predicting all the F1 data accounts, reposting that incident and that move and that crash and being like, ‘he's so bad, he doesn't deserve an F1 seat, blah, blah, blah.’
That's how the cookie crumbles with those accounts.
Anywho, we're not an account about, we're not a podcast about F1 accounts.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
No, that's what I mentioned though, anyway.
Moving on, I guess.
Feature race.
Again, we'll go through top 10.
That was Leon, Maini, Camara, Van Hoepen, Inthraphuvasak, Beganovic, Tsolov, Durksen, Mini, and Bennett.
And I'm pretty sure that is corrected.
Also, just to mention, Tsolov got a five-place grid drop for the incident with Montoya in the sprint race.
So he started five places below where he actually qualified and is what was meant to start.
On the bright side, for every time that I complain about Tsolov not doing a move right,
Camara also got dog-armed by Leon and Maini.
You know, usually I would say, hey, if there's a great driver, you know it happens sometimes that you are unlucky
and someone maybe crashes you, you don't have the pace.
But if you're Rafael Camara, and like, again, I'm sorry, but if you're in view for an F1 seat,
and you're getting, I mean, I don't want to get bad rep about him again, but I swear he had a fairly slow start
in comparison to Maini and Leon who got away.
At least it looked to me like they got away pretty well.
And that's just the kind of thing that you don't want to happen because at this point it's getting embarrassing.
You're in F2, you really need to make sure that does not happen.
Because again, for him, that just caused a lot of points that he could have on Tsolov who had a really sh*tty weekend.
Speaking of bad weekends for people, not Bilinski, Goethe, or Stenshorne's weekend overall.
I know we did say Stenshorne finished in the top eight, but...
That is also a fair point. It is never Goethe's weekend, but it was particularly not his weekend this week.
But Bilinski had a bad start, he just couldn't get away on the start, and then something happened to him.
I think he went in the pit lane, I think he did get going, and then...
He did. He missed the formation lap, but then he had to start from the pit lane, but not his weekend.
Bad weekend for those three, but expected weekend actually for Goethe, technically speaking.
I think overall, very little action happened.
Tsolov got a handful of moves done, but it's against backmarkers.
So it's like, wow, he got past Nicolas Varrone.
It's just like, I like him, and also the Van Amersfoort, that's like nothing. Doesn't mean anything.
Other than that, also, honourable mention to Dunne, locking up and going sideways in the pit lane for a little bit.
That was like seeing your long-lost lover, and I was like, that's prime Dunne.
Please come back home, the kids miss you.
I was getting flashback to last year when this would have been him straight up rear-ending Martins,
and it's like, you know, we did not appreciate how good we had it when we had actually drivers on the grid.
I'm not saying everyone is bad, but the level of talent has definitely gone lower,
and there's less drivers who we see with any kind of connection or chances in F1, and that's really sad.
From this weekend, I'd also like to mention that despite Bilinski having the most horrid weekend of his life,
Beganovic, for some reason, has had a pretty good one for once, yeah.
I mean, the podium in the sprint, and then actual points in the feature, and his car didn't stall or die on the first lap or anything.
Oh my gosh, what a miracle.
But I think it's fair to say that it was a pretty uneventful weekend in F2 at least,
and for the driver standings, I think nothing changed, but the gaps are getting closer,
and I think we're in for a really interesting end of season.
I'm incredibly hyped for Monza, because that's always one where I say a lot of important things happen,
but we're still with Tsolov leading the championship, but he's only 20 points in front of Mini,
and 20 points sounds like a lot, but I swear to God, in F2 it is not, and he's also just 22 points ahead of Camara,
like Tsolov is 22 points ahead of Camara, Mini is 2 points ahead of Camara in P3.
Dunne is with 108 points quite a bit down on them, like almost 40 on Camara.
You know, he needs to lock in to get higher, it's looking worse and worse.
And even with a whole ass feature win, Noel Leon is in P5 with 94 points, still 14 points behind Dunne.
I think we'll see some things to still mix up, but obviously the front was the most interesting.
I think team's championship actually kind of changed, because Campos is still leading quite a bit with 261 points.
We had it last week where I said that the top 2-4 were in, was a window of 10 points or something.
Obviously that changed, with Invicta rising from P4 to P2 with 187 points now,
MP lost the position and is now on 176 points, and Rodin is in P4 with 167 points.
I'm not sure if we had ART in the top 5 last week, but they are actually getting fairly close,
and if we keep these results up, they could even get into the top 4, maybe even top 3 of the championship,
because now they're in P5 with 147 points, roughly 30 behind MP in third.
And again, it's for both drivers, and we don't know, we don't know.
I think it's time we go over to F3 and consider whatever that qualifying result is, because I have in front of me, and I have so many questions.
Yeah, I woke up to these results as well, so P4 is certainly interesting to me. Let's go through the top 12.
So for F3 quali, our top 12 are Taponen, great sight to see, I think MP actually locked in this time around,
Slater, P2, Colnaghi, P3, Lacorte in P4, Badoer, P5, Ugochukwu, Nael, Rivera, Nakamura, Xie, Gladysz, and Le.
Here's the thing, once again, Ugochukwu going into the weekend as a championship leader, you do not want to be caught out by guys like Lacorte and Badoer,
like that's not what you want to happen. Like Badoer, he's been pretty fine this whole season,
and Rodin also seems to be kind of fine better than last year at least, but it's still, he didn't want it to happen.
Like I think he had not a good weekend, honestly all things considered. Taponen, as you say, it was really good to see him.
MP still whack with Giusti in, I think like he was in like P14, you know, around that area somewhere.
It was really disappointing to see him not, but I swear he hinted that there were problems.
But other than that, MP having Taponen and Colnaghi in top three was really the best quali result probably.
But also kind of sad because Taponen, Colnaghi, and Giusti are probably the lineup that, I've seen a lot of people say it pre-season, and I agree,
it's like the lineup with, even if we have other teams where like Slater I would say has a higher overall best what he can do,
it's the lineup with the overall, you know, best combined drivers because every other lineup has like at least one driver,
they're not as strong, they're not weak. And even if you say like MP is kind of not all three generational talents,
which is totally fine, it's still three really talents who are here because of their driving, not just because of money.
Technically everyone's here for money, but you get what I mean.
Yeah, yeah, I do get what you mean. MP does have the overall, I wouldn't, I'm not going to say best or strongest, but combined, yeah,
their results should show more than what we have right now.
Yeah, like if we assign everyone a number based on how we rate them, theirs would be the highest in team thing.
Anyways, sprint. Sprint started with a lap one collision between I think it was Gladysz and was it Xie? because I think Le got away?
Yeah, he got away, but it was Xie-Gladysz. Was Nakamura involved?
Okay, so this is the thing is that the original incident that was like under investigation, it said Gladysz and Xie,
but Nakamura was the one who was crashed off.
So when Gladys got out of his car all mad, the car next to him wasn't the DAMS, it was the Hitech of Nakamura.
And it's really hard to kind of, I suppose, explain what happened because there were like a thousand, not a thousand, but like obviously it was the midfield area.
So there was like at least seven cars swamping that one corner.
And it's just quite hard to see what happened. But I think yeah, I think it was just a lot of domino effect.
It seemed that Gladysz was just a passenger for the ride quite literally.
I don't think he could have done avoiding action.
Another really sad one because I was actually excited because Gladysz and Le both being in ART.
I'm a bit more fine with if they do well in F3 like the team because there's, sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm a bit more fine with the ART team doing well in F3 because that's drivers who I think also have like higher potential level.
And I was hoping to see a double podium at least, but was Gladysz, you know, crash.
I was a bit sad for him because he also seemed really pissed.
It was really a weekend to forget for him.
But who was able to profit from the situation was once again, Theophile Nael, who won the, did we go through how the race ended?
I don't think so. So it's time.
So it was won by Theophile Nael on the podium, joined by Kanato Le and Rivera, whose first name I sadly forgot.
I'm sorry, Ernesto Rivera. Good guy, good guy.
He's really, you know, getting the points also for Campos who's once again locked in team.
The rest of the points go to Colnaghi, Badoer, Taponen, Lacorte and Wharton, which certainly is a combination of drivers.
The bottom of that top eight is certainly something.
The thing is, what you might have noticed now is that there's two drivers missing here that you would usually expect to see the points, our championship leaders, Slater and Ugochukwu.
Slater, starting from P11, had, you know, a sh*t time anyways, because what do you do starting from P11?
Not a lot, especially on the Hungaroring, which is famously called Monaco without walls, there’s
Even here, we saw DRS trains.
It was pretty mild.
It's not a good track for overtaking.
Anyways, this was not helped by the fact that Ugochukwu, who did go into a good position to start, got a radio call being like, hey, take care of your tires.
No, like there's a bit of tire degradation.
You're like, be careful about it.
And because, you know, we're all grown guys, we know how to do this.
He answered with, you know, I know what I'm doing.
Let me do this.
Turns out he didn't know what he was doing because later on his tires were dead and he was just dropping down like dead weight.
But at the very least for himself, he was able to kind of keep Slater from pushing further and kind of boxed him in, in a way, which was, again, able because of that DRS train.
But it was just one of those moves where I again thought as at-the-time championship leader, do you want to do that?
Like, do you want to win your championship?
And I've said it.
Be safe, like don't crash at your opponent, but also maybe don't over push your tires when his teammate who started one place ahead of him won the race.
He didn't get points.
There is something to consider here.
Yeah, I think, I think part of it for Ugochukwu is that he hasn't really been-
I suppose you could say this far into a title fight on like one of the like, main seasons, if that makes sense.
What I remember is that's one of the biggest criticism points of him because while he's quick, it just feels like he can't put it together over a whole season, especially if, you know, season is longer.
And that's just something you don't want to happen.
Like, he did win Euro-4, but thankfully Euro-4 has like three weekends.
He won Macau, Macau.
Again, it's one weekend.
It's like, if it's a short season like quick race, he can do well.
Or he won FROT.
Again, it was pretty short if I remember correctly.
I think it was like five rounds or something.
Either way.
Yeah.
The thing is, he can be quick, but when he starts into a weekend and the qualifying doesn't go his way and like first race already also doesn't go his way, he can't, he doesn't seem to be able to do the whole thing for [???]
And it's really sad because I think in singular race, he's always, he always has the pace and he always has the ability.
But I'm just continuously, you know, kind of like, what are we doing here?
He could still be leading his championship if he didn't do these mistakes, you know?
Yeah.
I definitely feel like a lot of Ugochukwu's, like his season so far, a lot of it can just be attributed to him.
It's a lot of literally like, I think he just needs to find a way to properly lock it in over a slightly longer period of time.
Because if not, then we wouldn't be seeing, I mean, all this.
But he had it at the beginning.
I mean, he definitely has the talent and I think he's definitely driving a lot of people like because they know that he should be able to do it.
He just has to do, you know, something.
And either ways, I think it's time to go for the feature race because as I've spoiled, Slater took the championship lead by winning the race and being his first feature race win.
It took a lot longer than we expected.
Yeah, especially for someone who's in a Trident and also in general, he's Freddie Slater.
But I'll argue like the Trident thing.
I'll argue that even though we're in the Campos run this season, like I know a lot of people being like, oh my God, Trident and Invicta are the fastest and Invicta still over single lap.
Yes.
But I think that honestly, the Campos this season is better than the Trident in F3 because we see it that the main thing, the main problem that Ugochukwu and Nael have
is that they are, in my opinion, too crash-prone.
I'm like, there's too much going on there.
Rivera, who's, unless I'm absolutely talking bullsh*t.
Wait, let me check before I say something completely wrong.
And we can put that down on the list of Googling.
Yeah, Rivera, who even missed the first round, he's like in the third Campos and you'd think he's like the weakest Campos.
He is still, I mean, you know, Trident drivers, we can discuss that.
But I think he has had quite a stronger season than like, compare him to Stromsted, who's also in the Trident, but not doing what Rivera is doing, even though he has more experience.
Or he's at least not able to do what Rivera, maybe Rivera is just an absolutely great driver and we all underrated him so far.
Who knows?
Either way, the first, like, not half, but like, not even lap, but like in the start of the race was pretty thing because a lot of drivers struggled to get away and like it was kind of wack.
But then, you know, Taponen led, but it's an MP, they don't have that pace.
A bit of fighting, a bit of, you know, touching with Slater and then there was, I think it was a safety car, has to be, or at least a virtual safety car.
Because Taponen had a puncture.
It was a really weird situation in which the team was like, hey, you have a puncture, come in, and he comes in.
The problem is everyone followed.
It was actually a thing where they were, it took way too long to discuss that because it had to all be under investigation because regularly you're not allowed to enter the pits just for sh*ts and giggles.
But if I remember correctly, I, in that moment thought, okay, you know, maybe something happened on the main straight that everyone was told, you know, go through the pits to avoid what happened on the main straight.
You know, just like it often happens that when there's a safety car, they can tell them, ‘hey, take another route so you avoid the things going on there.’
But in this case, it was just everyone kind of assuming Taponen knows where to go.
Tapponen just wanted to do a pit stop.
I mean, I guess it's, I don't know if it's better or worse for him because on one hand side, he had to lead a few guys through because he couldn't just rejoin right when he was finished.
But on the other hand, regularly, if everyone would have done, would have gone over the main straight, he would have ended really dead last.
So I guess he was kind of lucky in that regard that even if he got that puncture, everyone else was stupid.
So he was still in the point positions later on.
Oh, good for him.
Yeah, it was like 26 cars, like literally the whole grid just followed him through and decided ‘yep, that must be it.
Not been told anything, but that must be it.’
I genuinely believe that if just like three or four guys would have done this, they would have penalized them.
I genuinely believe that because the problem was that if 26 cars do it, the only cars that wouldn't have been investigated were Tapponen and the guys that had already DNF'd.
And if, you know, I don't know what the regular penalty for that would be.
But if we say it's like, I mean, in this case, they take it as like, my god, you know, it just happened because it happens to the best of us.
That is not a good explanation, my opinion.
But let's say it was a five, it would have been a five second penalty.
Considering how close they were finished, it would not have any impact, except for the fact that Tapponen probably would have done and even though, he wouldn’t have won.
But he at least would have been quite a few points further up and it would have just been bullsh*t.
And all the teams would have complained and all the drivers would have complained.
Like, let's just let them do this.
I think it's just one of those things where you can't fight that.
I think the stewards probably just wanted to go home.
Like it took so long for that to come out.
They wanted to go home.
Yeah.
Either ways, it was a very typical F3 race after that.
You know, the AIX doing just whatever, a lot of just whatever happening going on.
Slater won as said, Ugochukwu could not get up to him and, you know, really fight for the win.
It did seem to me again that he just was not.
I mean again, Hungaroring, it's not easy to overtake anyways, but I think that could have been done more.
But that can also always be done more.
Yeah.
I think that's round about it.
I think there's a lot more important things to say about F3, except for the-
I do want to very quickly mention that at some point during the race,
we had Jose Garfias, who usually runs about P20, P24-ish, somehow managed to get his way up into P11,
which meant we were very close to triple Prema points.
I sometimes forget he exists.
Yeah, me too.
I'm going to be honest, it's a pretty weak F3 grid also.
And sometimes I just look at it and I'm like.
Especially down below where it's like drivers who don't come from like FREC or Eurocup 3 or like any regular series.
It's like, who are you? What are you doing here?
I'm sorry. Who are you?
And even with FRECA drivers, like you got to have done like the whole season and maybe not in like the last place.
Like, that would help, please.
Anyways.
Championship Standings.
Slater is leading now with 130 points to Ugochukwu's 122 points.
They're a pretty far set off, but nothing is set yet with Nael, who's in P3 with 75 points and technically could still win it all.
Who knows? Who knows? I'm afraid of Madrid.
I've said it a dozen times, I'm afraid.
Rivera follows very shortly with 72 points in P4 and in P5, but with 71 points.
So we will 100% see some changes in like at least P3 to P5.
Like there will be changes and I think it'll matter because we will see.
I mean, I'm just saying if Rivera finishes in the top three, which can happen, I think it makes his likelihood of going to F2 instantly a lot higher than right now where I'm still kind of assuming that he will repeat F3 in hopes of like, genuinely winning it.
Because after a season like this, you can only return to F3 to say you want to win it.
But then again, he will know that coming from FREC and so, are drivers with more money and more possibilities also.
And even if he has the connection to Campos and he saves Campos and is like the most experienced driver, I would be cautious if I was him.
Either ways, Campos is in my opinion, at least driver wise, they even if I complain about them, they managed to get more out of the car by also in teams championships being P1 with 269 points to Trident's 196 points.
Majorly because Campos has three drivers regularly on the podium, while at Trident it's pretty much Slater hauling the whole points.
In P3 we have Van Amersfoort racing with 132 points, P4 is Rodin with 121 and P5 ART with 119 points.
So pretty close once again in that 3 to 5 range of teams.
It's a good thing, I think, and it lines up that I think we could also see a drivers champion come from another team in the next few years.
Do we want to go on to our favorite Formula 4 series?
Italian F4.
My favorite Formula 4 series is actually British F4, but we're not going to discuss that today.
No, Italian F4 was at Mugello this time around.
Already starting with Qualis, we had something very interesting happen where in our Quali 1 and our Quali 2 groups, the polls were matched to the thousands.
In Quali 1 it was Weiss who set it, and in Quali 2 it was Cosma who set it.
And I think I remember, okay, so in Quali 1 it was Weiss, Aksoy, Maccagnani, Bondarev, Sammalisto, Hattemer, Bansal, Arn, Borenstein, and Bearman.
And in Quali 2 it was Cosma, Consani, Craigie, Costoya, all the Cs in one row I suppose.
Simek, Al Sulaiti, Repetto, Rechenmacher, Toniolo, and Bernoldi.
So when that pole lap from Quali 2 was first set, obviously there was the immediate confusion of who would take it and why they would take it, and on what grounds the ACI would allow them to take it.
A lot of people said that it should be, obviously it should be Weiss that takes it, because he, I think he set it first?
No, I remember it. It was really funny, because Weiss did it in Quali 1, but Cosma did it in Quali 2, but he did it like seven tenths of the second earlier.
From the start of the session to when they set it, Cosma did it earlier, but it was ruled then that Weiss still got it, because you know, Quali 1 is first on the track and has the worst track conditions.
And I think both ideas are bullsh*t, because it goes by this idea that we kind of know it from other series, where when you're in the same session, you set the same time, whoever set it first because of track evolution and stuff, the guy who did it first did it better.
But I think it's hard to apply that here, but I'm biased and I like Weiss, so I think he should have gotten the pole, and he got it.
Yeah, he did get it in the end, and I think a lot of the, what's it called, like the tiebreakers were in his favor either way.
But I do remember that for a second, ACI did announce that it was Cosma who got in pole, and that just did not make any sense to me. It was the stupidest reasoning for it.
Yeah, they’re all just bullsh*t, whatever.
So combined our top 10 for Quali was Weiss, Cosma, Aksoy, Consani, Maccagnani, Craigie, Bondarev, Costoya, Sammalisto, and Simek.
Once again, once again, I've said it a thousand times before, I think Bondarev isn't even in the conversation really for getting any title anymore.
But I'm saying, I'm still, I've said it so often, I'm almost sorry for him, but he needs to step up.
I mean, I think what I want to add here is that we, over the past few weeks, we've seen quite a lot of testing going on for like FREC and GB3 for like the next season.
And obviously these results at the moment, they really matter because they're what makes drivers decide, hey, do I want to do another season in F4 or do I do the step up?
And it also kind of matters to teams because while, you know, you can just play a team, especially the big teams, they also want to keep their reputation.
And if you were just bumming around and they have the same offer to pay from other drives who are doing better, it's looking bad.
Either way, I'm sorry, I'm sorry for all the Bondarev fans because I know he has a lot and I'm like, I hope he does well.
Don't worry, I came into the season very supportive of Bondarev and now sometimes I kind of go, man, I can't do this anymore.
Anyways, moving on to race one.
For race one, our top ten was Maccagnani, Craigie, Sammalisto, Cosma, Repetto, Hattemer, Aksoy, Costoya, Borenstein, and Ruta.
Just reading off the top ten, I would like to remind everyone that Cosma started on pole.
Unimpressed. We broke Samalisto's winning streak.
Yeah, unfortunately, we did not stop his podium streak, which meant he matched Slater for consecutive podiums here.
Slater, Freddie Slater. What is this grid?
Sammalisto, future F1 driver.
Don't say that! Oh, I was already crashing out about the Italian F4 intro for next year being all Sammalisto.
Don't say that he's a future F1 driver.
On the bright side, Craigie. Craigie had a pretty good race and he's had a really good weekend, actually.
And I've been, I've been happy about it because R-ace did not have the best general time so far.
Like his start to the season was a bit rocky, but it's, I feel like he's doing the opposite of what I criticized with,
with Ugochukwu earlier on in which he is not kind of, you know, losing his pace throughout the season.
But I feel like he's, you know, stepping up. He's getting better with every weekend.
Like I remember his first weekend in Italian F4, it was kind of like, sh*t man, that did not look good.
And I have to check before I say something wrong again.
But yeah, I mean, in the winter series, he may not have started out with like a win, but I feel like you see it in his driving style.
He's getting more, more adventurous. Like he's trying more things. He's daring to do more things.
He's getting that experience he really needs and it's, I think, a great look for him.
Yeah, and it's definitely also considering the fact that he's part of the Mercedes-AMG Junior Team.
I think it reflects just well on him as a driver, but also as a member of that academy.
Yeah, I think we can tell that he's one of the drivers that I've seen mentioned quite a lot of times in connection to testing in FREC already.
And honestly, I'm unsure because, you know, he did not have the best start to the season, but we can also blame R-ace a bit for that.
Either ways, I think if he goes on the way he does right now, he will also improve at the standings and it's probably a good shot for him to also make the way to FREC already.
Especially if you have to consider US Racing domination.
Okay, nuke US racing.
Yeah, we have to be realistic. What does he want to do? Does he want to do R-ace or something in peace?
I heard the rumors that he would do R-ace in FREC or does he want to do US racing just to like gain the title?
But R-ace is the Mercedes Junior Team, so like, let's be realistic.
Either ways, race two. One by my guy, my favorite, I'm really endeared to him, Ary Bansal. Great guy, I think.
Or I'm going to be, you know, shot by Robin if I didn't mention it. Andy Consani would have been P2 if it was not for the fact that Weiss had a horrific weekend in which he actually started on pole.
But Consani kind of like, you know, touched him a little bit, led to his like tire exploding or something. I know it was not exploding, but it's like he DNF’d . That was not good.
You know, I like Weiss . I like Consani. I like both of them. I enjoy both of them.
The question is, was this worth 25 seconds of penalties? Because I don't think so. I have never seen someone get a penalty like that or, you know, something like that.
Yeah, I heard people say it might have been because IF4 goes under that whole repeat offender sort of thing. So if you've done it before, they're going to make it harsher on you the next time around.
But I've never seen that on anyone else in the series. I've had someone tell me that they could imagine that the only reason that they're doing it for Consani is kind of to also protect Consani in the long run.
Because if someone who always ends up P30 doesn't even qualify for, I mean, Consani also doesn't qualify for the fourth race.
But what I'm trying to say is he's a driver that will surely make his way to FREC at some point. He's a driver that we all expect to see definitely for longer in racing.
And they said that–the one who told me this and the one who, you know, mentioned thinking that way–just said, you know, when you have 50 drivers and you have like every single race ends with like at least five DNFs and you have to rate between this guy who's like doing his first ever F4 race who will probably not even go to FREC.
Do you want to give him the big penalty if you're already annoyed by him and you just know they're going to do it anyways again and it won't help?
Or do you look at the guy who's, you know, doing pretty well, actually, but he cannot keep doing these things and, you know, you give him one sh*tty penalty and hope he never does it again?
Yeah, I...
At first I was like, that's ass bullsh*t.
But then I thought if I was a steward, maybe I would actually, you know, get down with it.
I would understand that.
I would maybe actually think the same because right now it's P2 in Italian F4 like whatever.
But if he does sh*t like that, say in the F3 final and he loses the title that way, it's sh*t.
But now he's like, I can never crash another guy.
I get f**king 25 seconds.
Yeah.
Got to be harsh on them kids.
Either ways.
So the final podium was, you know, as I've said, Bansal win.
Great.
Like Bansal.
Great guy.
I hope he does well.
Pretty sure he was also mentioned in connection to Formula Regional already.
In P2 we had Maccagnani, P3 Cosma.
Rest of the points go to Bondarev, Savinkov, Costoya, Bearman.
Bearman was also testing with, I think, what I saw, multiple teams, which is why I'm pointing this out.
Because I saw him test with both Van Amersfoort, I think or MP.
It was an Orange team at least.
And another team, potentially R-ace.
But either ways, a lot of the guys you see on top here are testing at the moment.
And maybe that's something that we should talk about in the future.
Also points to Repetto, Simek, Hattemer, and some other guys who get so little points they don't matter.
I also think it's interesting how well the Trident does on Mugello.
Because usually for IF4 we see maybe like...
I've already forgotten who's in the Trident.
You see maybe Hattemier get into the points.
But at this specific round, and I think it kind of shows in Race 2, a lot of the not lower cars.
But yeah, cars like the Trident were getting pretty consistent points.
Repetto, who's pretty okay, got higher points this time around.
And I thought that was quite interesting.
Yeah, I think it's maybe time to...
No, there's one thing that I forgot.
There's one thing that I forgot.
Oh my god, don't make me forget things.
If we're already talking about PHM racing, we should talk about Emma Felbermayr scoring another top 15 result.
To be precise, P14.
Which is also not like a lot, but it's PHM.
And what I really wanted to point out here is that I think so far this season,
she has been by far, in my opinion, the best performing female driver in this championship.
Because I have multiple reasons for that.
First of all, she is the only female driver to have...
Or no, there's also Rosanne Den Drijver.
But she only did one round, but those two, they have not once not qualified for the last race.
But she did three rounds, and she wasn't...
She didn't...
It's a lot of words. It’s bullsh*t.
She also has three times finished in the top 15, which again, it helps.
But more importantly, she's been almost exclusively been like...
I think this weekend was once again where she was like the second best PHM driver.
And you know, some of her teammates are questionable.
They have less experience than her and stuff.
But I think it's a good sign that she's, you know, up there and can be somewhat on pace with her teammates.
And you know, can fight further up, even if she has bad luck at some times.
If we compare it to other drivers like Payton Westcott and Emily Cotty, who are both with R-ace GP,
who I definitely expected to do better, because just by technicality, their cars are better.
But both of them, having qualified in certain race fours, have only gotten points once both times in P15,
while Emma Felbermeyr's best finish was P14 twice.
We have other drivers, we have other female drivers who have only done one round like Rosanne Den Drijver
And Zoe Florescu this weekend, who I'll also talk about later when we talk about race three.
And Rafaela Ferreira, who has the unlucky record of just never really finishing well.
Like that's just sad, I'm sorry. Please, please.
Either way, I think Emma Felbermeyr has shown some great, great things.
And I hope that we see her pop up when it comes to the testing for Formula Regional, because PHM is not, you know, a good team.
There's like, if you look at their team standings, it's regularly just in that 10 to 15 position of where they get their points.
And she's one of the drivers that does help them score points in, you know, the team's championship.
As you've mentioned, who was it?
Repetto is really, I think, outperforming that PHM. I don't know how he does that.
I haven't looked at his stats. I don't know how much experience he has, but I think Felbermeyr has been really good to me.
Yeah, so Race Three started on the safety car, mainly because apparently there's a thunderstorm right before the race was scheduled to start.
And so 30 minutes, it was delayed. But our top 10 on the podium was Consani.
I have to be excited for Rob. Al-Sulaiti and Bondarev.
And then for the rest of the points, it was Craigie, Simek, Aksoy, Killion, Sammalisto, Arn and Bansal.
And I like noticed it. This is kind of how we expected the championship to look like.
Not like, look like from the beginning, like this trend of Consani and Bondarev on the podium and then Craigie and Aksoy somewhere on like the rookie podium.
But also this was just a continuation of Weiss’ horrible, horrible weekend where he started on poll here.
It was comically evil this weekend.
And then within like the first few laps, he's already out.
It was just so bad. And within that few seconds between him being out and then the safety car being called, I think it was because it was wet and everyone who managed to do anything in that time were on like wets for tires.
Because Weiss was out and then, before safety car was called, Simek, Arn and Consani, Consani was on slicks, all managed to overtake Alp Aksoy who was leading from Weiss.
And so honestly, just so weird. Such a weird race. Such a weird start to a race actually.
The tires situation really made it interesting because Florescu, as I've mentioned, I want to talk about her, was one of the drivers on wet tires.
And I was aware that the wet tires were at some point at least kind of giving her an advantage over the drivers behind who were maybe, you know, regularly faster just concerning their cars and, you know, their experience.
But she was still running, I think, at best P14 in the race and I was really hoping that she could get some points.
Sadly, two laps before the end, she ended up in the corner. I don't know what happened.
Like, I genuinely don't know if there was a driver error or if someone, you know, touched her a bit or something or if she accidentally touched her.
Either ways, I think it was really sad because that race especially, she ran very well and she could have qualified for the fourth or in her case, third race.
And again, I know we would have been with a bit of luck in the fact that she was on the right strategy when others weren't.
I was sad to see her, you can kind of, you know, end a bit sad like this, but I think we could see her more often here and I hope we see her more often here because I have a good feeling about her.
I think if we have more races like this, she could definitely get some points.
Yeah, she had a really good showing, I think. I think at some point, she even made it to 13.
I was just looking down there because I'm honest, you know, because I knew you guys were looking at the top and if I was watching, I'm looking at everyone.
But as I was watching live, I was mainly looking at her, Felbermayr and Cotty.
And what was interesting to me was like, for example, what I always meant when I was talking that I think Felbermayr was more, you know,
was performing better to me than Cotty was that like, from the start, Cotty qualified like, I think, P18 or something, or at least higher than Emma Felbermayr just for after level one, their positions were swapped.
Like, even if the quali went to Cotty's favor in the race was just very quickly that Felbermayr had, you know, the better pace, the better control of the car, maybe also just the better tires.
I don't know, but it's something that I see so often from them.
To then see Florescu still faster.
And again, if Felbermayr had the better tires, there's only so much that even better tires Florescu could have.
Here's a good one though.
Should we move on to race four?
Race four was pretty typical Italian F4.
For our top 10 we had Craigie, Sammalisto, he came back, Maccagnani, and then for the rest of our points paying positions, Bondarev, Aksoy, Bansal, Al- Sulati, Consani, Cosma, and Repetto.
This one, the most typical F4 race you can have, two people crash, there's a safety car, it goes in, someone else crashes, and then there's another safety car.
But it also doesn't help that Italian F4 does not show everything.
Sometimes it's just the little messages on the bottom of your screen that says, oh, five cars are now being investigated for an incident.
To be fair, there's like 30 cars, it's impossible to show everything.
Yeah, I just kind of wish they would mention it sometimes, because it was also happening when nothing else was happening, so it's just like, oh, okay.
But a lot of these always end in the same way, if they've DNFed it's a good penalty for next race, but yeah, typical Italian F4 race for race four.
Just not a lot going on, it's fine, it's fine.
Yeah, okay.
Championship standings.
We still have, wait, we actually did end Sammalisto's podium streak in race three.
Okay, good to know. Sorry, didn't note that.
I do remember that.
Anyway, Luka Sammalisto is still leading with 288 points in front of David Cosma-Cristofor with 233 points, 55 points separating them.
But we have to remember, there is still three whole rounds going on, like, there are still things happening.
Don't be afraid, nothing is over yet.
Alp Aksoy is on P3 with 214 points, Ary Bansal in fourth with 198 points, and Oleksandr Savinkov in P5 with 168 points, but I won't mention.
Niccolo Maccagnani is only behind him by two points with 166, so there will 100% still be moves in the way it looks right now.
Oh, for sure.
Who knows, who knows.
As for the teams, we have US Racing very, very clearly leading with 604 points, to Prema’s in P2, 478 points.
Jenzer is in third with 162 points, which is actually insane.
I'm surprised.
P4 is Van Amersfoort with 151, and P5 Maffi 106.
I'm gonna be so honest, I have no idea where all the points for Jenzer has come from.
Let me check.
The thing is, the thing is, and what makes it possible for Jenzer to be so high, is that every team only gets counted with their, I'm not sure if it was top two or the two they choose before the weekend.
The problem is, US Racing and Prema Racing just block all the positions.
So Jenser is third, because even if they have not a single podium, it's enough that they have consistently been getting points and, you know, been somewhere that it, you know, helps at least somewhat.
On Wikipedia, Mugello isn't added yet for the team standings, but it's really funny because R-ace is genuinely in seventh.
Oh, they're behind Maffi?
Behind Trident, that's crazy.
That's crazy.
That's bad.
Oh no.
I would also just quickly like to mention where certain drivers of note are in the Drivers' Championship.
As mentioned before, Maccagnani is in P6.
Kenzo Craigie is in P7 with 144.
Bondarev is in P9 with 135.
And Consani is in P19 with 74 points.
I'm just like, okay, the title is kind of out of reach at this point, but I think, and I'm going to be honest here, unless, unless, you know, R-ace keeps pulling whatever they're pulling, I think the top 10 should be possible.
Because like right now on P10 in the Championship is Thomas Bearman with 127 points.
So it's like 50 points roughly.
I think that should be possible for him.
Just like if you keep in mind that a win is 30 points and, you know, everyone has all, so obviously scores points, but it should be, should be possible to not be in P20 when I'm saying that and he’ll end 25.
We would get somewhere, we get somewhere.
Yeah, I just, I think a lot for Consani has been like his multiple DNQs and so on.
It happens.
And we're also going to quickly go over the E4 Championship standings because we didn't have time.
Wait, before we go over the E4 Championship, I want to point something out, which is that Alp Aksoy is pretty, again, Mugello isn't added yet on Wikipedia, but so far he's roughly like 50 points ahead of Knud Nielsen.
And he's almost won every single rookie race.
So like he's, he's up there.
Knud Nielsen is P2 and, or potentially after this weekend, Kenzo Craigie could be P2.
I'm not sure about that one.
He's probably P2, but just to, just to mention, just to have it said out loud.
Yeah.
I'm surprised Nielsen even was P2 in the first place.
But yes, just quickly going over the E4 Championship, because last time it happened down at Paul Ricard, we didn't, we didn't have time to go over it.
So for our top five drivers, we have P1, we have Kenzo Craigie with 138 points.
P2 Samalisto, 124 points. P3 Alp Aksoy, 112 points.
P4 Consani with 82, and lastly Savinkov with 78 points.
However, I would just like to mention that P5 to P8 in the driver standings are only separated by about five points, and that Bondarev in P6 is tied with Savinkov.
For our top five teams, we have US racing again, leading with 150, then Prema with 130 points, R8 with 70 points, and then VAR with 14 points, and Trident with 8.
Yeah, I mean, no, I mean, you know, some things were a bit surprising, like no huge suprises. Is there anything, is there anything left to say?
Nothing for my end.
I think it was a bit of a boring weekend.
You know, we're nearing the summer break, there isn't a lot happening right now, but we're seeing more and more rumors for the next few seasons pop up and maybe that's something that we should discuss in the future.
Break testing, F4 testing, food testing.
So I think that does it for this episode. If you liked it, please be sure to give us a follow on our Twitter, Instagram, and TikTok at grandprixquel, and give us a follow on Spotify and Apple Podcasts under the Grand Prixquel pod.
Next week, well, we're actually unsure what we're going to cover next week, but we will have an episode out for you guys next week, so stay tuned for that, and thanks for listening.